welcome back to rockstars i'm eric voss
and loki has left viewers with a
terrifying mystery
what the hell is miss minutes the time
variance authority's adorable mascot
voiced by tara strong went from a mr dna
parody in the tva welcome cartoon to
a freakish roger rabbit bean capable of
jumping off the screen in episode 2.
can you hear me are you recording or are
you alive
uh sort of both
watch it where's your manners if this
doesn't worry you it should this is
witchcraft even for the mcu like what we
initially believed would just be a
one-and-done cameo keeps reappearing in
increasingly important and cryptic ways
and the mysteries of missed minutes may
answer our biggest questions about the
tva
in general hey by the way you can get
our amazing loki inspired latest
obsession shirt loki out of time and
other cool miss minute stuff at
newrockstarsmerch.com so the weirdest
thing we have to acknowledge is that
miss minutes is a 2d animated entity who
not only can respond line by line like
an artificial intelligence program
but can exist outside of the screen
display she seemed to be locked in
with no visible light source projecting
her and then physically interact with
her surroundings moment to moment
dodging loki's attack like a living
creature instinctively wary of pain
and this was not an oversight in pursuit
of a gag because the show's sound
editors went to the trouble of
adding sound effects for each of her
jumps little taps as her feet touch each
of the surfaces watch it where's your
manners and then a little click clack as
she jumps on the keyboard
so we began to suspect miss minutes when
we first met her in episode 1's welcome
video which
honestly gave us more questions than
answers contradicting the mcu lore given
by the ancient one
and suggesting mere mistakes like being
late to work could create a nexus event
that destabilizes the sacred timeline
and it all
ended with this hint that it was all
propaganda concocted by the tva
narrative commission but within that
animation the
wide shot of the tva headquarters shows
not only the looming statues of the
three
time keepers but if you look closely
another almost as menacing statue of
miss minutes herself also the voice of
miss minutes mysteriously echoes back
during the credits of episode one
thanks for visiting the tva don't
hesitate to let us know how we're doing
and miss minutes has been omnipresent in
early posters of the series before
anyone knew who she was
and tara strong has been top billed as
the character
in the primary credit sequence
accompanying a close-up of a binder
specifically for redacted reports
labeled as such right but most suspects
all over the tva like on the elevator
the chrono monitor switchboard the
handheld temp pads are
miss minute buttons for some selectable
function so what do these
do i have three theories for what miss
minutes could be theory one is that miss
minutes represents the timekeepers
she's the deputy and public face of the
timekeepers who stay hidden in their
chamber
like if the timekeepers created the tva
they could have created within it a
being made of chronal energy who could
simplify their wishes to tva agents and
the variants
like notice how the tba is a sterile
muted environment
devoid of visible magic except for the
tva time doors the temp pads weapons and
reset charges all of which
glow orange which is the same color of
miss minutes making me wonder if she
could be made of the same orange cosmic
energy that fuels the reset charges
taking a hint from miss minute's line
during the closing credits perhaps
hitting that button could send a direct
message to the timekeepers via miss
minutes about the status of the sacred
timeline
to let us know how we are doing but
there's a more
insidious explanation my second theory
that it has been
miss minutes all along it is possible
that the story miss minutes told us
about the timekeepers wasn't
fully truthful like maybe the
timekeepers are dysfunctional or
obsolete or even
automated machinery and that really
pulling the strings is
this little reality hopping demon miss
minutes if she
is really less of a recording than a
reactive moment to moment ai then her
entire explanation to loki was really a
speech
and presentation that she delivered live
which makes it less authoritative and
more something coming from a subjective
point of view and then think about it
that way suddenly a slogan of for all
time always
despite the same account claiming the
timekeepers emerged after a past
historical era of multiverse wars
that being so brazenly
self-contradictory makes a bit more
sense
like you could imagine miss minute says
something like the crease supreme
intelligence in captain marvel who takes
a different form to whomever sees it but
is really an ai designed to control the
functions of that society
thanks to nebia for sponsoring this
video nebia has a goal of saving a
billion gallons of water by 2023 by
creating the best luxurious functional
and water efficient shower heads
in the world so here it is
so namibia has partnered with moen on
their newest quattro design that just
launched her pre-orders on kickstarter
quattro is their most affordable
water-saving shower head yet
i know when i hear water-saving shower
head i usually think of showers with the
pressure of a leaky water balloon but
no nebia knows that they're not going to
achieve their conservation goals with
shower heads that people don't enjoy
using
and that's why their thermofluid
engineers have designed products that
make your home shower feel more like
a spa day the quattro has four spray
modes
none of which you'd ever guess are using
40 to 50
less water than a normal shower it's
also incredibly easy to install
in a two minute process that's as easy
as changing a light bulb
quattro is available for pre-order now
in chrome
matte black brushed nickel brushed gold
and oil rubbed bronze starting at 99
on kickstarter kickstarter backers can
also purchase the new quick dry earth
mat a stylish bath mat made from
dimetacious earth that rapidly absorbs
water so you don't need to wash it so
click the link below and pre-order your
quattro today
what reason would miss minutes have to
lie well as mobius explained for him
the tva is real merely because he
believes it's real he has never met the
timekeepers and i'm guessing neither has
c20 by the way i think they all just
know where their chamber is but other
than red slayer haven't entered that
chamber so this
legend of the timekeepers as heroic gods
is crucial to the tva functioning
properly
maybe there is no all-powerful god
lineup just machinery clockwork the
timekeepers could be part of that
machinery miss minutes could be the ai
that keeps it perpetuating
maybe in the past there was some master
clock maker who created it all who could
just be a very clever old man like he
who remains the one who built the
timekeepers in the comics but that
brings us to a third
darker option of what miss minutes is
miss minutes
is a cursed variant go with me on this
we've been asking what miss minutes is
but we also don't really know what
any member of the tva is are they gods
are they just
cogs in a cosmic machine taking human
form
in our eyes we know they have power over
loki and the ability to erase branch
timelines and variants
but these tva agents come with a lot of
quirks renslayer has a secret analyst
and some weird connection with one of
the timekeepers
casey doesn't know what fish are mobius
loves jet skis and
trusts the timekeepers inherently
despite never going near jet skis or the
timekeepers the series is also
repeatedly hinted at mobius leaving ring
stains despite not remembering doing so
now in the comics mobius has a series of
clones
maybe these stains were left by another
mobius a mobius variant and that got me
thinking
if we're now following a variant loki in
the kind of origin story showing him
becoming a tva
agent perhaps all of these tba employees
are past variants without timelines to
return to
which could mean miss minutes as an
extension of the tva's clockwork was
also a past variant maybe even variant
zero
a woman transformed into an
anthropomorphic clock as
punishment and before you laugh at this
beauty and the beast [ __ ] her video
specifically showed that yellow dude who
i call mr variant
shape-shifting into another inanimate
object a cup
actually we got cogsworth and we got
chip very beauty and the beast here i'm
just saying if a cup
why not a clock comment down below with
which of these three theories you think
applies best to miss minutes and again
support this channel by checking out our
loki out of time shirt at
newrockstarsmerge.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for loki breakdowns thank you
for watching bye
[Music]
you